c'est une aventure pas banal qui avaient
fasciné les français en novembre dernier
l'histoire d'un aventurier en danger
vers qui tous les yeux étaient rivés
c'est avec un post sur les réseaux
sociaux que l'aventurier mike horn avait
lancé l' alerte sur les grandes
difficultés qu'il rencontrait dans son
expédition en arctique visiblement à
bout de forces est bloqué par plusieurs
tempêtes de neige et le recul des
glaciers depuis leur départ fin août
l'explorateur et son équipier se
trouvait dans une situation très
préoccupante
au moment où je vous parle nous sommes à
bout de forces un poste qu'il avait
finalement effacé pour ne pas inquiéter
davantage ses proches mais très
rapidement la situation était devenue
incontrôlable
à tel point que l'une de ses filles
jessica accompagné des équipes de mike
horn et du journaliste hull ou clément
avait décidé de se rendre sur place pour
rapatrier les deux hommes en perdition
alors que beaucoup se demandaient si
cette mission de rapatriement avait ou
non réussi c'est l'aventurier lui même
qui avait annoncé la bonne nouvelle sur
les réseaux sociaux une opération de
rapatriement entièrement filmée par les
équipes de france 2 dont le résultat
sera à découvrir le 17 mars prochain
dans l'émission sur le fond oui avec mon
ami hugo clémente lembras hugo fort ça
s'arrête à un carton je pense et c'est
mérité alors quand tu arrives tu as
réagi quand appris que ton père était en
danger
il ya toujours un peu d'inquiétude il
nous faut toujours un peu dé frais à mai
mais on sait que quand il part dans
cette expédition et qui s'engagent dans
quelque chose de difficile il ya
toujours ce bateau risque d'arriver à
cette situation et après nous il nous a
appris à ne pas s'inquiéter parce que
comme ça qu'on va trouver des solutions
et c'est pas comme ça qu'on peut mettre
des plans de rapatriement en place et et
voilà c'est aussi d'avis que je connais
depuis que je suis toute petite île
quand même là c'est la première fois que
dans une telle difficulté mike mais ces
rires c'est vrai que quand on pousse les
limites chaque fois un petit peu
dépeuplé loi mais avec la fonte de la
glace la dérive de la glace
il ya un moment quand les températures
baissent à -40 tu marches sur un tapis
roulant avec la gasquet casse la base
c'est une zone de compression qui
claquent sur tes pieds tu dérive
beaucoup plus vite on à rire que tu peux
marcher en avant et c'est notre notre
monde est en train de changer
mais ça change beaucoup plus vite au
nord que qu'ailleurs et lui fait peur
pour ta vie un moment il coupe oui c'est
normal que que tu prêt la mort on a
assez de sentiment d'être vivant mais
quand on a plus de nourriture qui nous
reste en alu ge personnes nous
ravitailler un hélico peut pas venir
tu sais que c'est peut-être et dernière
jour tu dis un moment que c'était
derniers jours oui c'est sûr que juste
une semaine avant avant d'arriver au
bateau lagaf' dérivés honoré pis nous on
voulait aller au sud le fur à mesure
qu'on avance et la glace nous amener en
fait au nord et puis on s'éloigne de
notre but et c'est là où on a changé
notre loge horloge biologique
on a dit mais maintenant 24 heures par
jour et plus suffisant d'arrivée où on
doit arriver avec un orri turquie nous
restait et c'est là on prolonge notre
horloge biologique
notre journée devient 30 heures de l'ong
tudor 143 heures tout le monde chaque
heure et tu marches pas un inventeur
mais ça c'est déjà après trois mois sur
la glace dans la nuit noire complète
donc ça veut dire que c'est que je pense
la force mentale et cette envie de
revoir mes filles que j'aime ça supprime
un qui me donne là c'est un bide à
rentrer à la maison
c'est à donner de la force et puis jeudi
pour tout ce que j'ai fait de ma vie
vous et j'étais marié 25 ans ma femme a
décédé il ya quatre ans d'un cancer et
puis moi elle
j'ai eu envie mais comme personne n'a
eue
et puis après quand je disais à ma femme
écoute je ne vois pas ma vie sans toi je
préfère de mourir avec toi et puis là
elle dit
mais vie pour moi tu meurs pas pour moi
ses moyens jeudi la visite à ces
magnifiques par contre sont pas parlé
comme ça je sais c'est vrai il faut
aimer les gens dans la vie il faut aimer
il faut faut pousser les gens vers l'eau
long au pas de tir et en bas parce que
dès que tu tires quelqu'un vers le bas
tu tire toi même vers les bas jessica
j'ai l'impression que tu ta jamais peur
pour mon papa m'aime là quand tu ne dis
jamais que tu dises il va s'en sortir
mais je sais qu'il est toujours en
contrôle de ce qui fut fait et après la
nature est toujours plus forte ce que me
dit mais je sais qu'il voudra toujours
les bonnes décisions et je lui fais
énormément confiance t'as pas eu peur
d'arriver trop tard d'arriver trop tard
non moi je l'attendais de semaine moi
j'étais deux semaines en retard c'est
lui qui était alors les retrouvailles
étaient formidables puisque tu étais sur
le bateau et deux norvégiens sont partis
à la rencontre de mike les retrouvailles
avaient été folle on les a vus regardé
et on retrouva et voilà avec avec des
filles mike
[Applaudissements]
copé
[Musique]
est ce que est ce que depuis cet épisode
tu as peur de le voir repartir
j'ai envie qu'il reste un petit peu plus
à la maison là qu'ils se calment petit
peu mais je sais que ça va pas durer
dire il en bas il y arrive pas c'est
quand il est à la maison c'est comme un
lion en cage
on peut pas le garder très longtemps à
la maison n'a pas envie d'avoir un papa
qui est un métier normal parfois tu ne
dis pas ça qui fait tout ce que je
connais et tu étais fier de lui très
vraiment vraiment ouais c'est normal
quand c'était intéressant quand je fais
mais mon première explosion tour du
monde sur l'équateur j'écrivais un livre
et puis je lisais mon livre mes enfants
l'histoire pis après elle savait pas que
c'était moi qui a écrit laly qui a écrit
ce n'est pas leur papa c'était quelqu'un
d'autre qui a chopé les crocodiles qui
attrape et d'un singe
c'était à niort euros depuis exactement
ces héros puis les tirs vers il y avait
un jour quand ils sont arrivés à l'école
la maîtresse de l'école a demandé à
jesse cas que s'ils tombent papa il peut
signer un livre qu'elle a acheté un pays
en lice pourquoi et la maîtrise 10 mais
c'est ton papa où il découvre c'est
juste découvrent que leur père c'est
cela qui attrapent des crocodiles la
rivière
ça